let's go to another Bend this time we'll
go to Ben from France Ben from France I
assume this is you're coming from the
country of France is that correct
this is true welcome hey David yeah I'm
I'm actually American but I've been
living in France since about 2018. so uh
it's been it's been good here um what
are you over there having Health Care
without paying for it and stuff like
that do you think you're better than us
yeah yeah just for a quick anecdote like
I I I have had a small fracture on my
elbow a couple years ago and uh without
health insurance I had just a basic
Social Security I paid like 50 euros for
a couple X-rays and medication and all
that so yeah all right well and this are
you in Paris or elsewhere
uh I'm gonna be in Paris uh this
upcoming couple weeks uh but I live in
Brittany usually oh I have never been
but I hear it's delightful
it is yeah this is where actually my my
mom is from so I'm gonna have to get up
there all right I get those buckwheat
grapes you know I need those buckwheat
Crepes yeah not not quite the ones you
have in the US right yeah exactly all
right well let me not not take up more
of your time please go ahead that's all
right yeah I know so I've been thinking
um you know been living here for a while
and watching the the US content for a
while and I I noticed it's um really the
the culture wars is taking up more and
more of the air it seems like and uh we
don't quite have the same thing here in
Europe we do have somewhat of it but uh
you know I I still think like the the
workers issues and economic policy don't
get quite the quite the discussion that
they should because my I guess my
question for you is does this concern
you at all and like what economic policy
do you think would you like to focus
more on if you had more of an
opportunity to
um for example I've been writing for a
while on universal basic income
um I think unions are great but uh
unless everyone has a union it's unions
can become also kind of classist in
their own sense yeah no listen I mean
there is a sickness here in the United
States and I follow a lot of foreign
foreign to the U.S content creators
certainly many in France Italy and Spain
as well as in my birth country of
Argentina and elsewhere and what I what
I hear many of them say either publicly
or sometimes in private Communications
that I have with some of these folks is
that much of the world is looking at the
United States culture war and saying it
seems like very serious mental illness
quite frankly or short of it like it's
just the country has gone completely
insane and the stories around labor and
workers rights and getting to you know
we're at a point where we don't really
we could eliminate poverty we could
certainly eliminate hunger we could
certainly get everybody access to health
care and we're arguing about you know
like I said earlier Florida's Banning
Holocaust textbooks because they're woke
and someone showed a movie with a gay
character so now that's an investigation
it is a form of insanity and when you
step outside of the US even briefly like
I did a couple weeks ago when I went to
London you realize that number one this
isn't going on in the rest of the world
and number two we look insane here in
the United States
right so uh I guess well which which
it's it's true but then at the end of
the day you have to be thinking like
okay uh what what what kind of things
should we focus on if we had if ideally
we we could and you know the the
cultural War wasn't sucking up so much
air well certainly we should be focusing
on economics inequality workers rights
as I mentioned we should be coming
together to say hey here's what we're
going to do about climate change and
we're going to find the balance between
people getting to live the lives they
want and also not destroying the planet
here's how we're going to manage
emerging technology and we're going to
have logical conversations about
emerging technology here's a
forward-looking uh energy plan that's
going to get us increasingly on
Renewables I mean there's there's no
shortage of things that we could and
should be focusing on but to a degree
you know you can't ignore all of the
cultural stuff the right is doing
because if you do and they simply win on
all of it it hurts our ability ability
to deal with all of those other things I
just mentioned so it's a very tough
situation
it is yes and I I hope you get the
opportunity to do a little bit more I
mean I I don't watch your every single
uh video or email that you have but uh I
I do hope that you are able to you know
um kind of kind of cover a little bit
more of that and focus more about that
in the future again uh Universal base
can come in something that I've been
thinking about for a while it's an
interesting solution to me but I
obviously that's a that's a very big
conversation and I think it would be
nice to see different ideas and uh and
uh kind of like taking a little bit more
from ideas that are happening elsewhere
in the world not not so much France
absolutely absolutely Ben are you at
some kind of Carnival or Carousel
there's a strange it's almost like a
ding dong truck in the background
yeah you know actually I was I was kind
of trying to like look at that I I
thought I thought it was coming from
this server because I don't know where
it's coming from I've closed out all my
browsers and everything
um I don't know where this is coming
from but there's not an ice cream truck
outside of your window or anything no we
don't have those here wow we just have
uh yeah no no ice cream trucks
unfortunately but uh but I I'm okay with
the lower cost of healthcare that's very
good it seems like a fair trade Ben from
France thank you very much
no problem yeah all right there goes Ben
if you're like me and you love The
Nostalgia of enjoying a bowl of cereal
sometimes as an adult check out our
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon is the
breakfast cereal with the crunchy sweet
goodness you love but with zero grams of
sugar more protein and only four to five
net carbs so it's perfect if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto if
you're like me and you just don't want
to eat a bunch of sugar magic spoon has
delicious flavors to choose from cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter Honey Nut
cinnamon roll birthday cake my favorite
is maple waffle and right now they have
limited edition spring flavors
strawberry milkshake and peaches and
cream sometimes you just feel like
sitting down with a bowl of cereal when
the mood strikes go for something with
plenty of protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below